[Music]
all right on tuesday the franchise tag
window opens and this was davian clowney
last year at the draft saying forever
grateful will he be grateful if the
texans apply the franchise tag to
him you could argue that he should have
gotten his long-term deal a long time
ago he hasn't gotten it and who knows
when he's going to get it so we're going
to do now is we're going to have a draft
of the players who should be franchise
tagged in this cycle but let me just say
as a preliminary matter i think all
these guys should get long-term deals
yeah i don't like the fact that the
franchise tags in place i don't like
that you can artificially keep a guy
from hitting the market and getting
life-changing generational money i don't
like it one bit but it's not going away
anytime soon so we just have to live
with it chris thank you i'm glad you
said it too mike because it drives me i
think it's one of the dumbest things we
have in america i mean it truly is as
far as just professionalism i mean it's
the only thing i know well there's other
dumber things in america yes yeah
there's plenty of dumber things going on
it's one of the
in professional sports let me just say
that that's how i should better rephrase
it because you're right it's the only
profession in the world where they're
like hey you're really awesome at your
job you're one of the best there is but
we're not going to give you any
long-term security you got to prove it
to us one more year and while you're at
it while you're trying to prove it is
there's gonna be people trying to chop
block you and ruin your legs and your
shoulders and your knees and everything
else so uh i i wish it would go in the
next cba
all right well it's it's here for now
and we're going to do a draft of the
guys who should be tagged and uh chris
as always you have the honors
tales
it's going to be rigged let's see if
it's rigged today i think it's written
bam and it's always because all right
you get you get to go first they're very
happy that i'm back in the fold back in
the control room i mean having to deal
with you for a week straight is not easy
so they're like thank god chris is here
let's give him the tails never fails one
okay the first one is easy jodevion
county would be my top guy that i think
you need to franchise tag throughout
this whole process first of all
jiddevian connie i would be a little
scared of giving him a long-term deal he
has an injury history he had to get you
know the micro factor surgery on his
knee which means there's no cartilage
there which means it's bone on bone
which means it could go
any day and it's it's a worry thing it's
a worrisome thing and they are
constantly having to manage that but at
the same time he is still at this point
one of the best defensive players in
football i almost put him in the
category of a guy like michael bennett a
few years ago with the seattle seahawks
the stats do not tell the whole story
about jodevion county he deserves what
i've said to start the eight o'clock
hour mike crazy big fella i will i'll
just say this choose your words
carefully i'll just use a letter he is
the king of f the play up for all those
that are listening out there when it
comes to aaron donald was i thought
aaron donald was you're right that he
i'll give him he is the king of that
he's the king of all doing that and also
getting the stat lying along with it but
jaedevian clowney is the master when you
watch the texans on film of busting
through the line of scrimmage blowing up
the pulling guard now the whole play is
ruined the running back has to redirect
and it gets tackled for a two-yard loss
by you know bernardrick mckinney when
really geneviance ruined the whole play
and really was the reason the defense
was successful he's an amazing player he
would be my number one pick
well i'm going to stay in texas but the
other professional team there the other
nfl team there the dallas cowboys they
tagged demarcus lawrence last year they
likely will tag him again this year it's
going to cost them 20 million because
it's a 20 raise over the 17.1 they
received in 2018. and
one thing that's very interesting about
lawrence and i don't think he's going to
do it because 20 million is a lot to
walk away from he could do the le'veon
bell thing and sit out the entire year
and put the cowboys in position where
next year the franchise tag would cost
25 million or thereabouts it would be
quarterback money and that would
essentially guarantee a shot at the open
market or at a minimum the transition
tag where you go out and get a contract
from the highest bidder i don't think he
walks away from the 20 million though i
just don't know that you can do a
long-term deal with with lawrence when
the starting point is 20 million for
year one so i think he gets tagged and
they hope they can figure something out
and maybe they will maybe they won't
yeah i i know you know the interesting
there just to push back because i'm
supposed to push back against you in
these these kind of arguments is don't
you you're allowed to agree with me i i
mean i agree with you a little bit but
you're mike florio so i want to disagree
with you a little bit too um you know
they do have a lot of defensive linemen
there in in in dallas and they are
having to worry about some future
you know contracts here at some point
whether that's ezekiel elliott or dak
prescott and getting those things done
you know 20 million dollars for a guy
that got 10 and a half sacks and you got
a lot of other defense alignment on your
roster i'm just throwing it out there i
think they will franchise them franchise
tag them as well but i'm just i'm just
throwing out you know some food for
thought
all right
give me who else you will take because
you would have taken lawrence if i
hadn't taken him in round two no i would
not i promise you i would not have taken
him i would take i would have taken
frank clark or the seattle seahawks
first uh the reason being more than
anything frank clark is unquestionably
the best player on that seahawks defense
uh i believe at this point in in that in
his career and he's the leader of that
defense in this point of his career he
kind of made those comments during the
year remember when richard sherman was
kind of talking out about the seahawks
and he was that you know he's not here
anymore he's not here anymore this is my
locker room it's my defense now and uh
he is a phenomenal football player they
can't afford to let him get out the door
or even hit the free agent market
in the slightest bit he sets the
attitude for everything pete carroll
wants on a defense tough hard-nosed you
know doesn't say a whole lot but plays
hard and is a phenomenal football player
so i give him uh my second pick
yeah and and i don't disagree with that
and they have the luxury of being able
to afford that cap space for
frank clark because they moved on last
year from a lot of the overpaid guys and
eventually frank clark will be one of
the overpaid guys that they move away
from but for now he's in that sweet spot
where he can get money yeah he's better
off getting a long-term deal but
franchise tag or two may be what he has
to accept all right i i i say this next
one reluctantly the guy is very good i
just don't know how the chiefs are going
to pull this off they can pull it off
short term long term they are facing
some real issues with some of these
young star players they have to find a
way to keep d4 around past we know
quarterback's the most important
position on the field number two is pass
rusher and it's not a coincidence that
all four of these guys so far that we
have picked are pass rushers but with d
ford he wants to be there they want him
there and i think this is the year to
use the tag on him because next year who
knows where it goes you got chris jones
who's coming up next year you've got
tyreek hill if you don't sign him
looming is patrick mahomes i think we're
going to see ford get tagged and we're
going to see guys like justin houston
and eric barry be gone they're going to
build around the young guy and they're
going to go through a mini seahawk style
transformation where we see some of the
older guys in kansas city cleared out
because they're building around the
young guys and they're going to try to
hold as much of it as they can together
while they still have patrick mahomes
under his rookie deal because that
changes everything once they have to
give mahomes that gigantic contract that
is coming for him yeah no i i don't i'm
with you with d ford i think that at the
very least they do have to franchise tag
him and i think he's the perfect
franchise candidate too anyways i don't
know if i would feel comfortable about
giving d ford long-term money at this
point he's really this is the first year
he's really jumped on the scene he's had
some moments uh leading up to this but
this was the most consistent play we saw
from him he was uh phenomenal coming off
the edge and to your point too yeah the
chiefs are in the window right now and
he is their best edge pass wrestler the
justin houston era is has come to an end
it's d ford and chris jones and like you
said they have some other things
prevailing there they got to figure out
but i'm with you there all the way
yeah they're going to clear
plenty if they move on from houston and
that's one that we need to be keeping an
eye on they will they will clear plenty
of cap space almost enough to afford d
ford's franchise tag just by moving on
from houston right um okay so my third
round pick um i think you left some good
ones on the board here
go ahead yeah i think um oh i don't know
what you're taking a lot of time here
they must not be that good no i just
don't know which ones you left two i
think they were better on the board this
is where i just end the draft because i
win just mike drive it's philip
bustering by the way not philip busting
welcome back
philip busting
oh no problem i still don't even know
the difference of what i said and what
you said so
philip busting is what the 49ers used to
do to your dad oh phillip they used to
just bust phil is what you're telling me
yeah yeah yeah yes yes thank you for
making it clear it was it wasn't very
clear from the term so i'm glad you
spelled it out
grady jared i'm going grady jared here
for the atlanta falcons we talked to
thomas dimitrov uh
you know at the super bowl he told us
that that was priority number one for
their football team this offseason grady
jarrett this is the seattle defensive
scheme he is their michael bennett in
the interior part of their defensive
line he's a special guy who can hold up
his you know rush or his lane and and
clog the middle of a defensive line
because he can hold double teams and do
things like that for that atlanta
defense but he's also one of the most
athletic 300 pounders in all of football
and he can shoot the gap and be you know
a poor man's version of an aaron donald
but for a team that uh you know has a
good defensive line but not a great
defensive line this is the best player
on their defensive line they need to
keep him if they want uh to continue to
have this great dan quinn defense that
he created in seattle going
yeah there's a lot of pressure on that
team to to turn it around this year
arthur blank's been patient i don't know
how much longer he will be patient and
you can't let that guy walk away and
it's another defensive lineman pass rush
remember that game he had super bowl 51
did he have three sacks in super bowl 51
right and uh you got to keep that
that's the only antidote to great
quarterback play guys who can put the
quarterbacks on their rear ends all
right that's all the pass rushers i've
got i'm going to landon collins the
giant safety they don't have many great
players on the giants they need to keep
the ones they have unless they trade obj
they got to keep landing collins around
he's the leader of that defense they
don't have a lot of talent up front like
they used to have they're trying but
collins is a guy they need to keep
around look at all the money they spent
on defensive players a couple of years
ago when they got olivier vernon janoris
jenkins uh snacks harrison
you need to reward financially a guy
that that arrived via the draft and is
is dude a bit to be paid and look if
they're not going to pay them a
long-term deal use the franchise tag and
keep them around yeah i get that i guess
you're right i mean they have safety
issues there on their football team so
that's the one area i go okay that makes
sense i mean certainly but at the same
time i guess the other thing i worry
about is just the way that landon
collins plays too right it's such a
physical way in which he plays we saw he
missed a number of games this year
because of that and you know i don't
know that's the tough i mean what's the
franchise number for safety is it going
to be around like 12 million 10 million
along those lines somewhere in there um
i think you could have just done better
and picked cj mosley with that third
pick that was just where i would have
gone just to let you know just you know
so that's a fourth great pick for me
stats i won this one don't be afraid to
say it
no it doesn't matter what stats thinks
and
you didn't get a fourth round i'm just
all right i'm surprised i'm surprised
you didn't pick steven gazkowski no no i
don't pick kickers i don't do that crap
you know here's the thing we got to take
a break but the patriots have had two
kickers since 1996. yeah adam vinitarian
stephen kiskowski but he missed a kick
in the super bowl and he almost missed
the two that he made i think they let
him walk away and don't use the tag on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports